I know it's hard to pinpoint something
like this but why do you think people
have latched on to this series what is
drawing people into this and keeping
them so interested in season after
season Vikings is a show that is
centered around family drama it's a show
about the people and the heartbeat of
the personal relationship between the
lost Brooke family and Ragnar and
lagertha and now the sons of Ragnar and
a real culture that we all are
fascinated about and we haven't really
seen too much of and every season just
gets better and better and I'm so proud
to be now part of six years of epic
television making and a show that has
actually number one in the world right
now I think I read the head is somebody
sent me an article and I'm dippy were
rated as the most popular show so I'm
just so proud that finally people are
actually catching on and getting a
chance to see Vikings and watching it
and as binge watching and I couldn't be
more proud of it it's incredible and I
thought that job of an actor you've been
in the industry for a while you know you
never know if something's going to hit
or not or what's going to happen with a
film or TV show I'm just wondering when
you're reading ahead on a script or
something are you constantly kind of
like am I gonna survive this one I do
have that fear well when you're shooting
a show called Vikings
no one's ever saved really Michael Hurst
laughs and he says that he has the
actual ax at the end of the day which he
does and but it's it's one of those
shows that it still feels like a gift
every time you read a new script and
we've one single writer that writes
every single episode and to be such
challenged as an actor for six years of
constantly storytelling it's constantly
evolving your character that is
something that was one of my biggest
fears actually signing on to his show
for six years actually four years and
then two years after that was how am I
going to be creatively fulfilled with
one character for so long
I have to say Michael definitely doesn't
ever make me comfortable or keep me
comfortable and challenges me as an
artist and creatively I get a chance to
try different layers and you will seal
Agatha in a completely new light this
year you will see her totally in a
different physical space mental space
spiritual space and she will have a
massive transformation look forward to
it now I know you also are branching out
into other things you directed an
episode in season six
tell me about directing an episode of my
games how did it go were you nervous is
it just total whelmingly exciting was
there a lot to learn
I just finished directing an episode and
I I'll tell you one thing it was the
most rewarding and scariest thing I've
ever done in my life it was so
challenging to be able to show up every
day in make your days because you're
battling so many different elements with
light and daylight and wind and rain and
different types of continuity and
children and goats that are ruining your
shots because they're screaming and and
there's so many different things that
you can't even control when you shooting
Viking especially with with being in
Ireland and in such a massive production
that it was a challenge every day and we
had to shoot now we're shooting in
January and descent in February that
we're day late independent for the most
part of it so I only had a didn't half
hours to shoot a day so you had to be
extremely efficient and I will tell you
one thing is I could not do it without
the incredible crew this crew has gone
back as far as the Braveheart years
they've been there every step of the way
as an actor to be on set to help you get
the best performances but also as a
director they really wanted to help me
to be able to tell the best story and to
be able to give back to the Viking
series behind the lens
and I'm extremely private and I could
not be here without them you might hate
me for asking this question but tell me
one thing you learned about yourself
when directing one thing I learned about
myself directing Vikings
my first thing I want to say is fake it
till you make it because sometimes when
you're scared out of your mind you're
like how am I gonna make my day how many
get my shots how am I gonna get this
performance out of this actor and or how
am I gonna be able to shoot when there's
rain or lack of rain for so many
different elements that you can't
control I I was keeping my fingers
crossed and I tried to act like I was in
control meanwhile I'm freaking out
inside but I will tell you one thing I
was not late I did not go over time and
I can't take the credit but I have to
take credit with the hard-working crew
and they push through it they knew the
clock was taking and they all pitched in
and helped to be able to help me make my
day so I'm grateful for that thank you
so you make it thank you to you make